ce matin il ya une grosse opération de
police anti-drogue sur le quartier du
tennis puisqu'il ya eu plusieurs
événements sur ce quartier là depuis
plusieurs mois et donc suite un travail
là aussi depuis plusieurs mois et une
grosse opération était menée ici mais
pas qu'ici dans plusieurs villes en
france puisqu'il avait des connexions un
petit peu partout voilà depuis 6 heures
ce matin grosses opérations cédées moi
d'en quête des mois de travail collectif
et moi je salue le travail de toutes les
forces de police mais aussi des autres
personnes qui ont travaillé au quotidien
je le dis souvent c'est un travail
collaboratif entre police justice la
ville du creusot et tous les
intervenants qui au quotidien bon faut
un travail de fourmi ce que les
habitants avaient bien entendu du mal un
petit peu à entendre parce que encore
une fois l'objectif il est bien
d'arrêter mais il est aussi que ces
personnes là puissent rester en prison
longtemps et ne pas ressortir derrière
donc c'est un l'autre il ya un problème
au quartier du tennis au creusot oui un
problème bien sûr c'est ce que je disais
il ya eu un phénomène de trafic qui
s'est déplacé de grandes villes ici au
creusot comme dans d'autres villes parce
que c'est un phénomène national et
depuis plusieurs moins effectivement il
y avait des bandes venant de paris de
lyon d'ailleurs qui faisait leur trafic
ici parce qu'ici on est dans les villes
plutôt tranquille donc pour travailler
c'est plutôt plutôt mieux